c'est lui cyrano
ravi de vous rencontrer cyrano de
bergerac
vous êtes un monstre
monstre
[Applaudissements]
entendre amis je serai très fâché si
vous mourriez
[Musique]
hydro one of them all
she may seule raison d'être sur terre et
d'aimer roxane le cheptel le monde
n'acceptera jamais quelqu'un comme moi
avec une femme grande et belle
nous sommes démunis un bon mariage est
votre seule option je n'ai nul besoin
d'être je ne suis pas en détresse
l'amour ne signifie rien à vos yeux les
enfants besoin d'amour les adultes
d'argent
c'est un aveu à vous faire à moi je suis
amoureuse ils partagent peut-être vos
sentiments à vrai dire je ne lui ai
jamais parlé de votre amour de quoi que
ce soit
s'appelle christian christian deville
est c'est une nouvelle recrue dans votre
régime hortefeux n'est scène il se peut
qu'il me déplaisent et hommes comme
roxanne veulent de l'esprit je ne sais
pas parler d'amour je suis poète mémo au
bord de tes lèvres je ferai de toi un
homme romantique tu feras de moi un
homme séduit sens
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
au
talent
[Applaudissements]
mon amour pour vous est si puissant mon
amour pour vous est si puissant il a la
force terre coeur il a la force de tes
recul des reculs tu n'as rien mieux vaut
parler moi comme vous le faites tant
faut l'être vous êtes une fleur
ravissante je ne suis pas une fleur
c'est tant mieux
tu es amoureux tu es
mon destin et de l'est mais de loin
c'est à elle de décider de notre sort
elle mérite d'avoir le choix
[Musique]